well all eyes are on the delta variant
which has about 150 confirmed cases here
in nevada
according to health officials on
thursday johnson and johnson reported
its vaccine to be effective
against the delta variant both moderna
and pfizer's
two-dose vaccine hold the highest
protection against the virus
unlv's assistant professor for
infectious disease
brian lubus says the delta variant is a
strain of the covet virus that is
circulating at a rapid pace
other strains will mutate over the years
he says the people should be concerned
especially those who have not been
vaccinated
the biggest difference between this
strain and the other strains is that it
spreads more easily
we haven't seen it causing a different
disease more serious disease more
hospitalizations or anything like that
it's really the person-to-person spread
that's the big difference so of course
that's going to lead to
a lot more transmission the community if
it spreads more easily
he says the only way to know if you have
the delta variant is through a
specialized test
at the state public health lab a normal
cova test will not tell you what strain
you have
he says it doesn't change how you are
treated but it's important for tracking
the variant
he added that the best way anyone can
protect themselves is by getting
vaccinated